a falta de ácido no estômago pode causar
problemas de inchaço na barriga porque é
no estômago onde o ácido clorídrico
quebra os alimentos e ajuda na absorção
de nutrientes conforme a gente vai
ficando mais velho ou velha a tendência
é que a produção de ácido vá diminuindo
e se a acidez estiver baixa os alimentos
ficam no estômago por mais tempo O que
explica o inchaço e a retenção de gases
a ingestão de antibióticos e antiácidos
podem também causar esse problema para
resolver isso você pode consumir
alimentos que estimulam a produção de
ácido clorídrico como é o caso do suco
de limão o vinagre de maçã e evitar
alimentos que irritam o estômago como os
processados e que TM alto teor de açúcar
dica de ouro experimente a suplementação
com cloridrato de betaína para aumentar
os níveis de ácido clorídrico no
estômago mas pessoal antes de fazer isso
e por sua segurança consulte
profissional de saúde de confiança